assalamualaikum we're gonna go ahead and
post this wonderful group of people who
are coming in to learn about Islam and
Muslims so let's go ahead and meet our
friends who are coming in from I believe
it's Michigan let's go ahead and answer
their questions make them feel at home
make them see that it's not a
bomb-making factory that they're coming
into they're coming into a house of God
house of worship where Muslims come
those who have submitted their will to
the creator for our doing Islam trying
to acquire peace by submitting their
will to the owner he's the one God the
one Creator is not a man or woman but he
created men and women and the list of
goes on of things that they're gonna
learn but the main thing is that they're
courageous enough brave enough to come
and make the human connection to remove
the ignorance which will remove the fear
and through that that we can establish
more of a peaceful and harmonious
society with our neighbors and friends
colleagues we'll see there come on let's
go ahead and check it out so I'll make
them notice now everybody they come in
and disperse now go back to work but
this is Juma
[Music]
y'all know y'all know y'all [ __ ] we had
[ __ ] be either
[Music]
have you seen these apps where you can
kind of make yourself generate yourself
to a certain age in the future it's cool
but kind of scary is it so it reminds me
of this story about elderly lady she's
in her in her 80s and she's feeling that
death is about to approach many people
have signified that any kind of kind of
sometimes you don't know when it's
coming but you know you can feel
sometimes that it's almost here she was
describing how she can almost feel that
the moment is coming we don't know the
exact time and what happened was her
life she's going over the highlights of
her life which pretty much can take a
few hours
and she recollect that the first part of
her life you know she lived for her
youth which are days that are far gone
and she can't remember much of that
because it's over and done with money of
those things we don't even remember then
she grew up you know living for her
husband she got married which he ended
up passing a long time ago and then she
lived for her children who now they have
children and families of their own they
also have left on and now she's by
herself
and these were the main focuses of her
life there's nothing wrong with any of
these things but now this is all that
her life was focused on and now she's
just wondering what really was life
about and this is where the essence
starting with the story is before we get
into some of the details of Islam and
hijab and jihad and terrorism and all
these things that are real hot topics
and people want to know about but this
is where it all starts it starts with
the individual really reflecting deep
down in themselves and asking those push
elections where did I come from
here where am I going when I die and
then a person if they don't suppress
what's already in there their nature the
belief Oxford did a study with 57
academics in 22 different countries and
they concluded that the belief in the
divine and God is just something just
naturally a lot of us forget that
because we're in the concrete jungle
we're gonna get out of nature and do
more flexo with the whole new atheism
and people end up denying that reality
they see the basic belief system of
belief and only one God belief into
angels belief in the messengers that
these angels brought the revelations to
the books and now confirming the
confirming the day of judgment that
these messengers warned people and gave
the glad tidings and about paradise and
Hellfire and the day of judgment and God
is not ignorant of anything he knows all
this is all the destiny of God now this
is the belief system you say okay this
makes sense all this evidence adds up
cut me in what do I have to believe you
believe this and now you say that's it
now you do because talk is cheap you
have to back it up by action those the
actions are the five pillar something
you've heard allah mohammed rasoolallah
there's nothing worthy of worship
there's no god but god nothing worthy of
worship except the one God and Muhammad
is His Messenger so we got the five
dusta Shahada the testimony because now
you believe it testified to it and live
by it so you have these components now
you establish the prayer God I don't
need our prayer we need it so it's time
what we believe is God created Adam in
His image that's that's what it means
so what that means is that he didn't go
to the embryonic stage I'm saying so he
was created just like a whole man you're
just waiting man the end is coming
they're gonna get him all right now
imagine put that and at the end you
would end up throwing potatoes or what
tomatoes and what not if he got away
with it weren't you right you get it
because that's justice is something in
green
we want justice right this is at the end
you know how many people are getting
away with injustice
how many who end up in two courts but
still the criminal the mafioso the
gangster is so called and that person
pays off the the attorney pays off the
judges pays off with the bribery he
person gets off there's a beautiful
passage in the Quran it goes like this
cool off I had Olaf was summoned let me
lead the Wellum you let one in the
cooler who could one had where God
Almighty is saying that say he is Allah
God the one and only the absolute the
eternal the self-sufficient doesn't eat
drink he doesn't do the things that
human beings do he doesn't become born
doesn't die he doesn't have children he
doesn't have a family he doesn't have a
son a daughter he doesn't have this
human lineage that human beings - it
doesn't be getting or is he begun
there's nothing comparable to God
nothing that you can imagine that's
comparable comparable to you now he was
the Sunnah gate that that deity and the
same thing now with being all-knowing
everything as soon as he's ignorant
about something see we you might be a
specialist in math science and then you
two come together experts in these
fields but now you're scratching head
you got to hit Google for the plumbing
job or for or something else because
they are ignorant in certain areas
God is not ignorant anything he's
all-knowing his knowledge encompasses
all things so that's the call to you God
that's when we talk about the Creator
that's the one guy
you could be one of those go ahead and
make an employment call the any Masjid
mosque in your locality in your city
Chicago
check out the MCC Muslim community
center you can go ahead and request me I
can go ahead if I'm in town if I'm
available be your host be your tour
guide answer your questions and help you
take that learning to a whole nother
level learn and grow and get to
appreciate what close to two billion
people in the world are appreciating
Islam a submission to the Creator not
the creation living life according to
how the crater wants us to live